So tell us take us into
the jury deliberation room.
Like,
how long did it take to was was everybody
in agreement
that she wasn't at fault
or did it take some convincing?
We were all in agreement.
So
it took us about two and a half hours.
And it was a very interesting time.
I think we had all waited two weeks
to speak to each other.
That's just crazy to see something
and hear all this evidence
and the law and then wait
two weeks and finally
get to talk to each other.
It was it was really interesting to see
we were all on the same page.
Okay.
So it took your two and a half hours.
I mean, what took so long
if you got in there
and you were all on the same page?
That's a good point.
Well, there was nine questions,
so we had a lot to decide.
And it was really hard to say
that Terry Sanderson was
at fault because,
you know, it seems like just an accident.
Right.
So I think that was probably
the hardest part of it for us.
But I think right off the bat, it made me
took us,
I don't know, less
less than
20 minutes to say
that Gwyneth was not at fault.
And so was there a particular moment
in the trial that convinced you?
Was there some compelling evidence
where you figured, okay,
that's it's not her fault?
I think her testimony really made sense.
And I felt
like she was telling the truth.
However,
there was a lot of evidence provided.
I mean, this is eight days of evidence.
So I think hearing her expert
witness, Dr.
Shaw, really brought it home for me
at least to hear him validate
that her version of the story
was actually the most likely.
And was there a moment
where you ever thought,
but she's an award
winning actress, maybe she's bluffing?
Absolutely.
I mean, I had to keep that
in the back of my mind.
But then at the end of the day,
we have to treat everyone
the same in the courtroom.
And I think that's our job as the jury
is to
look at all these individuals and,
you know, forget
what they do for a living
or anything like that
and say this is a person
and we have to treat them all equally.
When you were called for jury duty,
at what point did you realize, oh,
I'm going to be on a jury
with Gwyneth Paltrow as the defendant?
When did that realization happen?
I don't think I realized
that until I actually
got into the courtroom
on the first day and saw her,
because when they said her name,
I was like, oh, that's interesting.
Somebody else would name their child,
Gwyneth Paltrow.
Surely she's not in Summit County.
That makes no sense at all.
I was pretty shocked.
Yeah.
Oh, I bet. That's amazing.
And one last question there.
There was some talk
about how Terry Sanderson's
attorney
seemed to be kind of taken with Gwyneth,
like seemed to be asking her
lots of sort of starstruck questions.
Did you get that impression
when you were in the jury box?
It was interesting
because that was the first
female attorney to get on the stand.
And so I couldn't tell if it was just
because she was female
or if it was because she was starstruck.
And I couldn't really tell.
But there was some
there was more light to that testimony
than any of the other ones,
and it was pretty entertaining,
I will say. Yeah, I bet.
Well, Sam, thank you very much. Thanks.
I really appreciate
you taking us inside there.
I bet that was a fascinating eight days.
So we've been watching
and we really appreciate
getting your perspective.
Absolutely.
Thanks for being here.
All right. I'm back with my panel now.
Monday, RC, Joe and Patrick.
Yes, we get it in New York.
By Tuesday, I mean our jury, our dress.
Yes. Yes.
You know, you have something going on.
I like
just the way she talked about,
you know, the jury doing their job.
She needs, you know, the grand jury
evidence of grand jury. Exactly.
Yes. Yeah, the two of us.
I'm glad you two were entertained
by this story, have to say,
because it is so hard
to take this trial seriously.
And she did.
Obviously, as a juror, that's her job.
But I'm going to put this out there.
My husband will be very pleased
that I am sharing his conspiracy theory.
Oh, great.
He believes that this was scripted
and it's going to be a movie
and we're all going to find out
because the characters
were so crazy and weird and eccentric.
So we're going to find out
there's reality
show that Gwyneth Paltrow is starring in.
This is his theory.
I think it's a lot of trouble for that.
Lot of legal trouble. Yes.
Yes, obviously.
But he but it would be a fun plot.
But it's so wild.
The quotes were wild that both attorney
you know, the attorneys,
next thing you're going to know A Yeah.
Is going to write the script, right?
That's right.
Or maybe the next part.
Or maybe it did already.
He already did. Okay.
But she was talking about the
the plaintiffs attorney
who we were wondering
if she was starstruck.
So let's just play a 20 seconds of this
so everybody can get this impression.
You were wearing goggles.
A helmet?
Yes.
Kind of look like
everybody else on the slope.
That's always my intention. Okay.
Probably had a better ski outfit, though.
I bet I still have the same one.
May I ask how tall you are?
I'm just under five.
Ten. Okay.
I am so jealous.
I think I'm shrinking, though.
You and me both.
I have to wear four inch heels
just to make it to five. Five.
So they're very nice.
Oh, thank you.
I was yelling at him.
Patrick, what's happening now?
I mean, that's that.
That's just A-plus right there.
I mean, that is just too good.
I mean, talk about a performance
right there.
But you know what?
In all seriousness,
I mean, I give her credit for saying,
you know, this is absurd, right?
That this guy brought this
for going through with the drama
and going through with it
and just saying
they had an accident on the ski slopes.
I mean, come on.
This happens all the time.
And this guy had to you know, then
in between the time
when the accident actually happened
and he was supposed
to have had all these issues.
Right.
He's he's hiking, he's ziplining.
He's whitewater rafting.
You know, that was on his social media.
So he gets his taste in wine tasting.
Right.
I think that was one of the damages.
I guess she
also lost half a day of skiing.
So please,
I just think at some point
we're just going to stop calling things
a hot mess.
A whole mess is just going to be a whole
goop, right?
It's just that's just
just that's
going to be the into perpetuity.
Just it's it's a good scoop.
It's a group call the day.
I don't know.
Yeah, but I thought that that attorney.
Well that was a tactic,
I thought that was a strategy to do,
but to get her comfortable.
I've been deposed
and I've I've had attorneys
try to sort of like soften you up.
And I know your approach is cops
are you're used to this
and then they try to get you to relax.
I think that's what you know,
it was like something I thought
I thought it was too.
I mean, so
and I've said this before, I thought that
at least that's
that was her original intention.
Maybe that clearly that wasn't
how it was perceived
by many people in America.
But my sense was
she was trying to sort of
not just disarm her, but
but also to make it seem to the jury
that this is actually someone
who is an unusual woman. Right.
Because,
you know,
she's a she's famous
and she doesn't live
the life that the rest of us live.
And I thought that that was the angle
she was trying,
but it seemed
and to the contrary,
that she was just fawning over her.
I think it's also that old theory.
A half truth is a whole lie,
and it's like she's JQ
She won't even tell the truth
about how tall she is. Right?
And so it becomes he's shrinking.
That was his problem.
And he got caught lying about his height.
The whole thing was crazy.
Well,
you guys have a lot to say about it,
which I really appreciate it.
Thank you all very much.